we covered using service level
indicators to measure the reliability of
our services
and using service level objectives to
set reliability targets
in our first episode but what happens
when our service has a problem
and we start burning our budget how can
we configure alerting to let us know
that our users are unhappy while
managing our operational load
today i'm going to show you how to
calculate and use air budget primary
thresholds
as an optimum approach to your alerting
setup welcome to engineering for
reliability with google cloud
to help us let's review chapter 5 of the
sre workbook called alerting on slos
if you haven't read it before no worries
we'll link to it in the episode notes
below
the main thing we need to take away from
that chapter is that the best way to
have sufficiently sensitive alerts
while at the same time reducing false
positives is to use multi-window
multi-burn rate alerts but first what's
a burn rate
air budget burn rate is a measure of how
fast relative to your slo your service
consumes error budget
for example a service that has exactly
zero error budget left at the end of the
slo valuation period
has a burn rate of one a service that
consumes all of its air budget halfway
through the
slo evaluation period has a burn rate of
two and so on
we calculate our burn rate by looking at
three main inputs
the slo and its evaluation period the
amount of air budget consumed are burned
and the window over which that burn
happens that's our alerting window
let's walk through a specific example
let's say our service has an
availability slow of 95
over a rolling 28-day window we want to
know if we're having a problem that's
impacting end users
a great place to start is to create an
alert that lets us know that we've
consumed
two percent of our air budget in the
last hour we use this equation to
calculate the burnary threshold for our
alert
which is 13.44 we also want to know
if we're seeing a slower burn rate too
five percent of our budget in six hours
this time our burn rate threshold is 5.6
we want our alert to notify us only when
we're still actively burning error
budget to reduce the number of false
positives
to do this we'll create both of our
alerts with two windows a long window
and a short window a good starting place
is to make the long window
12 times as long as the short window by
using multi-window alerts
we keep our detection time low and
minimize our reset time
so the alert doesn't keep firing once
the incident has been mitigated
okay that was a lot the main thing to
remember at this point
is that we can use air budget burn rate
alerts to detect issues with our service
long before our slo is actually
threatened now let's have a look at how
to set them up in cloud operations
start at the dashboard page select
monitoring from the products menu
and click on services
here's a service with an availability
slo defined but no alerts configured
the slo is evaluated over a rolling
28-day window
in order to create an error budget burn
alert for the slo
you need to specify two things the first
one is the look back duration
or the window over which the error
budget burn rate is evaluated
the second entry is the burn rate
threshold
or the value of the burn rate that must
be true over the look back window for
the alert to find
to configure a fast air budget burn rate
alert that'll fire if two percent of air
budget is burnt over an hour
set the look back duration to 60 minutes
and the burn rate threshold to 13.44
for a slow burn alert that'll fire five
percent of our budget is burned over six
hours
set the look back duration to 360
minutes and the burn rate to six
name your loading policy
specify your notification settings for
the alert
provide any documentation or additional
information that should be delivered
with the alert
and save the alert policy
finally confirm that the alert has been
created now if the availability
of the service degrades the alert will
fire and an incident will be created
we've configured an alert based on air
budget burn rate threshold
but what happens when it fires let's
have a look
let's see what happens when an air
budget burn rate threshold alert fires
from the services overview page we can
see that we have a service with an slo
alert fire
we can show just those services with
firing alerts
we can go to service details to confirm
that we have an unhealthy slo
with a firing alert
we can expand the slo to confirm that
we're seeing a degradation and a service
level indicator
on the air budget tab we can confirm
that we're starting to see additional
error budget burn
further down we can see the logs being
generated by the logs for our service
in this case we're seeing an increased
number of 500 server error logs
confirming that our service is currently
having an issue
thanks for joining me today we covered a
lot you'll learn
about why alerting on air budget burn is
a great way to balance
keeping users happy against operational
overload
we then figure out how to calculate our
budget burn rates and saw how to use
them to set up alerting
for your services and cloud operations
thanks so much for watching
don't forget to like and subscribe to
never miss out on more engineering for
reliability with google cloud
see you soon
you